hi everyone my name is Philip and I'm a
technical lead at Target faith and today
I'm going to show you how you can deploy
hanging face Transformers to Azure using
the hiding phase Azure ml endpoints we
start at the Azure partner and the first
thing we need to do is to search for our
hiking face Azure ml endpoints we can do
this by searching for hugging and then
at the marketplace section we should see
the higher face Azure ml endpoints
and this will bring us to the the
marketplace offering we can click on
create which will then allow us to
create our hiding phase managed
application on azure as a resource Group
I'm going to select the test Resource
Group here you can select the resource
Group where you want your managed app to
be deployed region we are going to go
with the East US region the name will be
hiking face
video and the application it's also
going to be hiding face and the managed
Resource Group is not important it's
basically where later all of our Sr
resources are stored you can change it
if you want but you can also leave it as
it is and the next step is text we don't
need any text right now and then we can
go to review and create
which will validate our inputs and then
we have to access the conditions this
basically means that you as a user
allowing us hiking phase two later
deploy or create resources for you
and now we can click create what's now
going to happen is that our manage
application with some base Azure
resources are going to be created this
takes around one minute after the
deployment is done I'll be back
the deployment of our managed
application is now complete and we can
now start creating our HTML endpoints
therefore we go to the resource which
will bring us to our high in phased
manage application and then on the left
side we can find under resources preview
hiking phase endpoints which is our
central place for all our hiking phase
endpoints later meaning we will have an
overview of all our created endpoints we
can add more we can delete them or edit
them
obviously since we created our managed
application we don't have any endpoints
available yet therefore we will add one
and to create a new hiking phase
endpoint we only have to provide a
hiking face model ID and need to select
an instance time for our model we go to
the hiking phase hub
select the model in this case we will
use the digital bird base uncased
fine-tune on ssd2 which is a distribut
model fine-tuned for text classification
we go back to our Azure resource paste
our high infest model ID and then we can
select our compute instance time here
you need to make sure that you have
available srml compute for your instance
so the drop down is showing all
available Azure ml instances but it's
not validating in the UI if you have
capacity or not so in our case if we
would like to deploy a T4 you have to
make sure that you have available
capacity if not the creation will fail
but for our case we don't need a GPU we
will go with the F2 series which is the
CPU optimized instance for our model
then we can hit review and submit make
sure that we have the correct model ID
yes and our instance type and then we
can and click submit and now our
resource is created on the top right
side we can see it's creating resources
meaning that our backend is now
validating all of the the information we
provided meaning that it checks if the
model ID we provided is a valid model on
the hiking face Hub it also makes sure
that we have enough capacity available
if for example we wouldn't have enough
capacity for our F2 instance series we
would see a failure here and then we can
go to the details and check what is the
arrow and then we should see out of
capacity
a few more seconds and then we should
see our green checkbox and also should
see our first endpoint with endpoint
creation state
also something pretty cool about the
hiking face
um srml endpoints is that we are
automatically deriving the task for a
model so you have seen that we only
provided a model ID and didn't provide
which task we want to use the task is
automatically derived from the model
information so we didn't need to specify
that our model is a text classification
model this this was done automatically
and while I was talking our validation
or custom resource
was successfully created and the
dashboard is currently loading so yes
perfect here we see our new endpoint
with our status which is currently in
creating and within five to ten minutes
our endpoint should be created and then
our deployment was also created once
this is done I'll come back
foreign
the deployment of our endpoint succeeded
and we can now see that the managed
application
derived the task we can also see our
endpoint URI which we they could
directly copy and paste into our
application we can see our instance type
as well as the Azure resource link which
we are going to use to test our endpoint
we can copy the Azure resource link
paste it into our
browser which will now like jump into
Azure machine Learning Studio to our
endpoint which has been created in here
we can go to test
and can test our endpoint the endpoint
is using the same API schema as the
hiding phase inference API meaning that
we need to provide a Json with the
inputs key and then a sentence
this model runs on Azure I am
happy
and now I can hit test and we'll get
back our positive from our model
also if you want to integrate it into
your application HTML provides code
Snippets for python C sharp and R which
you can directly copy and paste into
your application as well as you can
regenerate your keys in case of any
security guidelines
okay and then we can go back to our
overview of our managed application
and
could either create more endpoints into
our hiking phase application or we can
again delete our endpoint
um
yeah if you have any questions about
hiking face srml endpoints feel free to
reach out to us via email and when you
deploy your manage application there
should be a support email you can
contact or we also have a dedicated
section in our hugging phase Forum since
the purpose of this video was to demo
you how you can create it we also make
sure that we delete our endpoint to Safe
resources which will now deleting our
custom resource
should reload in a second and then we'll
clean up all of the
infrastructure behind the scenes
thank you
and bye